we've got a report out today which
suggests a third of young survivors of
the Manchester Arena attack
um haven't received the mental health
support that they perhaps would have
liked they've not received any
professional support you've spoken out
about wanting to challenge the stigma
around mental health and and about your
own mental health have you sought
professional help for your own mental
health over the last few years can I ask
well firstly dealing with the magic
Arena young people it's an outrage they
don't receive the help they need we do
know there's big problems with child
adolescent Mental Health Services but
it's not good enough and the more delay
there is before you receive professional
help the worse your mental health gets
I'm blessed I'm surrounded by experts in
relation to my physical fitness and my
mental Fitness both of which haven't
been 100 but but the key thing is to get
advice uh particularly if you're a man
my gender my sex don't talk about or
having problems we ball it up and that's
why one of the biggest causes of death
of men my age is suicide so I've talked
about my mental ill health during the
pandemic but also because of the
cumulative impact you know been doing a
stressful job for a number of years and
I've got help and I'm better for it and
the same goes for physical fitness as uh
well we're not embarrassed to talk about
being physically unwell we've got to not
be embarrassed about being mentally done
well
in your book breathe you talked about
the possibility that you you think you
may have had a minor heart attack at the
cop 26th Summit I mean you know in terms
of physical and mental health your team
describe you as being in rude Health do
you feel you are
around 5K this morning so I hope my
doctors are watching and are impressed
at my uh Fitness regime look it's really
important to craft yourself uh it's
really important to make sure uh you're
not sacrificing your mental Fitness and
physical fitness because of the job you
uh life and it's really important to get
treatment one of the reasons why Kirsty
speech today is our frustration that
around the country there are many many
people missing out on the help they need
I'm not in any way uh you know bringing
equivalence between what I've suffered
and others whether it's a grown full
tragedy whether it's the terror attacks
you talked about the Manchester Arena
but all of us have got to recognize that
if you don't look after our mental
Fitness and physical fitness they can
deteriorate rapidly and so I'm in good
health uh hopefully that was a first and
last issue in relation to my heart but
I'd encourage anybody watching this just
to make sure you're looking after your
own health
because you you're bidding for a record
third term as mayor next year do you do
you think you are fit enough to do it
absolutely look I mean the key thing is
to make sure you get regularly checked
up you know regular examinations in
relation to my heart in relation to
talking to somebody regularly about my
mental uh health and I'd encourage
everyone to do so and all these things
you need to medicalize you don't need to
necessarily go to a doctor for some of
these things having a friend to talk to
can often help with your Mentor Health
doing exercise could often help with
your physical uh Health eating the right
things can often help so I'm not just in
baby way everyone should go and see a
doctor or a psychiatrist or a
psychologist but there are things we can
do to make sure we look after ourselves
and prevention definitely much is better
than uh cure but I'm ruined to go in
relation to the mural election I can't
wait for the campaign to begin I think
everybody in the country is a Tory
members running to be the Tory candidate
for uh whoever they elect I'm looking
forward to a good clean contest
and you're down there at the Elizabeth
line promoting that today and the fact
that it has finally opened officially
what difference do you think that's
going to make to travel in London
well it's been almost a year now since
we opened the Elizabeth line her majesty
and eight Majesty opened Elizabeth line
last year over the course of the last
year the great news for our country is
we've contributed to the country's
economy more than 42 billion pounds this
line is now the busiest line in the uh
country at more than 150 million
Journeys on this line over the last year
every day more than 600
000 people using the line the reason I
mentioned those numbers is it shows how
this piece of infrastructure is helping
our cities uh recovery that's why it's
really important for us to persuade the
government to invest in these pieces of
Transport infrastructure the Elizabethan
in London high speed for the north high
speed two we need a new cross trail in
London more investment in our Bay clue
Line new trains across our country
that you've you've championed to have
been things like the low transport
neighborhoods I don't know if you've
seen the report out in the times today
which suggests that their research shows
that these low transport neighborhoods
aren't actually achieving what its hope
they would achieve because obviously the
point of them was to reduce Journeys on
on the roads their researchers showing
that there is no evidence that these low
traffic neighborhoods reduce the number
of miles driven and in fact
it could be that they're in increasing
the number of miles driven because
people can't get from A to B through it
so they're driving around it which is
then adding to congestion and miles
driven on on local roads what what do
you think of that I mean you know it's
they're suggesting that simply
greenwashing it's simply just not making
a difference
well I think the question is who are the
best people to decide what happens in
our communities is it civil servants in
Whitehall or is it locally elected
councilors decide what weapons in our
communities in London where a population
of almost 10 million everybody jumps in
their car there simply isn't enough Road
space for people to drive around our
city so we've got to encourage people
talk cycle use public transport and the
evidence with the low traffic
neighborhoods in London in many parts of
London whether it's Lambeth Northern
Forest or newham is fewer road traffic
collisions when there is a road traffic
collision the consequences are far less
serious so fewer deaths it's leading to
a few people driving their cars because
they're walking cycling are using public
transport we're now more than 500 School
streets encouraging children and their
parents and their carers to walk Scooter
and cycle to schools so the quality of
the air is improving as well so you're
tackling climate change you're improving
air pollution and reducing congestion
but you're only you're only doing that
in the little area that it is if you're
unfortunate enough to live on the edge
of one of these low transport zones what
this research seems to suggest is that
actually it's getting worse for the
people living on those roads it's not
actually cutting the journeys yes it may
be cutting Road deaths in that
particular area but if it's just forcing
the problem elsewhere that's not solving
the problem is it's just moving it to a
different part of London
yes well those borrowers that I
mentioned have looked into the issue of
displacement that's what you're
referring to as displacement at the
evidence in those boroughs who have
successful ltns because they've
consulted they've engaged they've worked
in them is there's few people driving
but also there is no displacement the
issues the question is this
should somebody in white Soul who
doesn't know a community decide where
the money is spent or should a local
Council working with neighboring
councils I don't even think City Hall
should decide what happens with these
individual streets because I'm too
distant from these councils I think
councils should decide what happens on
their streets of taking back control is
to me what it says on the tin it
shouldn't be Brussels to Whitehall it
should be Brussels to Whitehall to
councils across the country but but
whether whoever makes the decision the
fact is if this has been promoted as a
green scheme that actually improves the
environment and the research shows it
doesn't prove the environment it doesn't
matter who's making the decision whether
it is the city hall or whether it's a
local Council it's actually not
improving the environment in that local
area
but it but the reason why who decides
what happens is important is because
where counselors decide what happens in
London there's been big improvements
including in relation to the environment
this is an issue of the environment and
also health and also the economy
congestion is bad for the economy carbon
emissions is bad for the climate
particularly amount of nitrogen oxide is
bad for uh health and by councils not me
not civil service in Whitehall not
Richie sunac but Council was deciding
where the ltns are you have successful L
chains some ltns aren't perfect some oil
change need amending some may need taken
out so what I'm saying is cancer should
be in charge of what happens in their
communities fnltians is imperfect
they'll tweak it they'll amend it
they'll remove it because obviously they
want to make sure and ltn is uh
successful this is about devolving
powers and resources to local decision
makers who will make the right choice in
relation to the environment in relation
to the health and relation to the
economy